to this day like people who maybe they
would consider
in their definition that i'm their
friend like non-muslims
um because i'm just friendly i
you know will talk to them ask them how
they're doing i'll be concerned like oh
you're sick can i do anything to help
you
i'll be their friend like that but do
am i spending like quality time with
them am i like really
am i like going to tell them my most
vulnerable things like i would with a
close friend like my bff uh no
like the thing is that you like
the people who are really influencing
you are your best friends your closest
inner circle and you want to make sure
that that close
inner circle is good people because
those are the people that you could end
up
being resurrected with like in
yomokiyama when allah is going to raise
you
it's going to raise you with the people
that you love
right the people that you are so close
to
that you love them and you don't want to
be raised if someone is bad
right and you know that they're doing
the wrong thing they believe the wrong
thing like they're
worshipping you know a man or they're
worshiping
other gods you don't want your afterlife
to be tied to that
so you have to be very practical this is
not a joke like
we only get one chance at life and you
don't know if
how long you're gonna live tomorrow you
know i might be gone
in the next 10 minutes you know i might
end this call with this
uh with you guys and that's it so i want
to make sure that i'm not taking any
chances with my
and your close friends and the people
that you
love in that way that is a big factor
that is a huge huge factor so don't
gamble with that
[Music]
look at your own mindset look at how you
think like oh i want to get this
so then i'll be good like i want to be
making x amount of money
so then i don't have to worry about like
paying bills or paying for food or
going traveling and doing this this and
that um
i want to lose this body fat so then i
could be defined so then i don't have to
think about like i have
this much fat on my body i want to have
this much muscle on my body on my frame
to where it's like when i look at myself
i'm happy with what i see
it's like our mind's always trying to
get to that state where it's like okay
i'm good i don't have to
do anything else now i imagine being in
jannah was like
you don't have to make money you don't
have to
eat food you can eat food if you want to
enjoy yourselves
but you don't have to right you don't
you're not
you're not uh at the mercy
of uh like your vices if you have any
vices
like you know sex i'm sure bro i'm sure
we could have sex
in general but proper sex and without
feeling like we're addicted to it
without feeling like we're being
controlled by it so it's like i don't
know about y'all but that seems
that seems pretty perfect
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to t3m
if it's your first time here
hit that subscribe button but if you're
returning hit that bell notification
and consider becoming a patron we are
joined here with a special guest
daniel hakikichu also known as the
muslim skeptic
it goes without saying it's a special
guest because you see angel without the
tank top
but shout out to you bro for even
looking fresh in a tank top
i'm gonna let romney take over
[Music]
this lovely brother here he runs the
youtube channel the muslim skeptic
he is the founder and director of uh
alaska institute a learning institution
dedicated to answering the question
why is islam the truth so if you're
looking forward to learning about that
then go check it out
insha'allah it's not institute again his
academic background is a double major of
physics and philosophy from harvard
university
as daniel studied under some of the top
physicists and philosophers in the world
including nobel prize winners
to our brother daniel all right i'm
sorry
i catch you very happy to be here thank
you happy it is our pleasure having you
on mashaallah
so we um like we talked about we planned
to have you on
about a week ago and um there's actually
an unfortunate delay do you want to talk
about what that delay was
yeah basically we went back to
prehistoric times
in a sense because we lost electricity
the
power grid of texas failed and millions
of people
were without power and this was due to
freezing temperatures
uh below zero temperatures that hadn't
been seen
in texas for about a hundred years
so we had no power and we had no
therefore we had no heat
but we were able to manage it was the
more difficult because i have kids so
young kids so they can't understand
why is it so cold dad and just turn up
the heat
but we had family close by
who their power was um fine
so we were able to camp out there for
about four days
it reminds me oh my bag away bro that
have you i was just gonna say i feel
like um some good reflective points you
know would come from that like
how much we take for granted on a
day-to-day basis subhanallah
absolutely um we just don't really have
a sense
of how delicate all these systems are
that provide
convenience in every aspect of our lives
so that's something that i definitely
was feeling
last week
bro my dad when he was living in puerto
rico
um the latest hurricane that passed that
hit puerto rico really hard
left puerto rico without electricity for
weeks
bro he told me that like he would go
outside when
it was like starting to um
what do you call it when the the sun's
about to go down
uh sunset but like after like right when
it's getting like really really dark
he said he would look out and they would
remind him of those uh
zombie movies it was like an apocalypse
and there was just like nothing man so
that's that's the power of allah like
something as
you know just the temperature dropping
and all of this
advanced civilization uh can just go
dark
so supposedly advanced yeah that's a
good reminder yeah man but i mean i
don't wish that for
i only sh that for anyone like a lot of
people actually died because of the
the cold so um you know may allah
protects
us from these kinds of natural disasters
but
definitely something to remind us of
death and the nature of this dunya
that's such a good message because a lot
of guys and girls that are in that
predicament right now when this is all
over life
goes back to normalcy but for a lot of
people
this is normalcy yeah for sure for sure
it's fun a lot it's uh i was joking i
was joking with uh
or my one of my teachers was joking with
me he's a teacher in egypt
i have and he was saying that you know i
heard what happened
and i think i should start collecting
aid humanitarian aid
for you in the i'm gonna start u.s some
money
and don't get me started the amount of
tweets i see about um
you know the us just being an undercover
third world country with makeup
it's real man yeah i think i mentioned
um
on on one of the uh the other videos
that the us has spent so long preparing
for a war that they weren't prepared for
anything else
like uh you know pandemic um mental
health issues and all these other things
it's yeah i i don't think it's like an
exaggeration
to say that you know there could be huge
third worldification in our lifetimes of
the us
like uh and according to some analysis
a lot of the infrastructure is so old
all across the u.s not just in texas
it's like only it was only meant to last
like 40 years or 50 years like electric
grid
water sewer system and so we're way past
the life expectancy of these systems and
there's been
no money put into actually
overhauling them and bringing them up to
standards
so it won't wouldn't take much at all to
put the entire us in the dark or worse
and it seems like no one's really paying
attention to
these kinds of things because of the
amount of corruption in the u.s
yeah jeez when you add to that the fact
that the us gives what millions of
dollars a day to israel
what is that yeah it's a big joke
yeah all this money but they but you
mentioned like
wars and just you know trying to
dominate the world
the thing about the us is they have this
kind of cultural agenda they want to
make every
where westernized so like when there's
this uh
part of the spending bill like the
relief bill that congress was trying to
approve
and there's that 10 million dollars for
gender programs in pakistan
right so why do you want to mess with
gender
in pakistan you're spending 10 million
dollars of tax
money instead of helping people
you know helping people who like are
living without clean water in the united
states
places like flint michigan instead of
working to fix
that you are trying to do a cultural
engineering program
across the world it makes it makes no
sense
but this is the nature of u.s politics i
don't think other countries necessarily
have this kind of cultural imperial
imperialism the way the us does yeah
yeah subhanallah i'm getting the same
vibes i was getting when i was uh
watching your your most viewed and most
popular video on youtube masha allah
what was it like five hours long five
and a half
yeah yeah the debate yeah yeah
subhanallah um
i think it's definitely a very
interesting debate i think uh you know a
lot of good reflective points came from
it i think it was
um highly educational for a lot of
people and i think um
it really spoke to you know your
opponent and his uh
academic um um
what's the word academic um
we're talking about the one with apus
yeah yeah
how you know academically disingenuous
he is um
when he said um what was that point he
made um
that uh our wars are a lot more bloody
because we have
like uh weapons of mass destruction
yeah yeah you said something like that
something like islam didn't have weapons
of mass destruction
so that's why they didn't use it like
what yeah
very um yeah yeah that's this is the
kind of
it's like you can't even understand what
he's trying to say for most of that
debate
like he was just all over the place
and it's because he didn't expect his
views to be challenged
like and a lot of people with that
mindset who are coming from this
uh kind of modernist uh you know liberal
secular perspective
they just think it's common sense like
their way of doing things the way that
the west is run they think that's just
the standard default that all human
beings rationally believe
so then to start raising just obs
obvious objections critiquing it as a
shock like they have never gotten that
before
and that's why he had to you know
sputter about and
really made a fool of himself
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah
and 100 um a lot of atheists
they don't know that um even things even
the fact that they're
atheist right is making certain claims
right so
holding an atheistic position is is
conceding or
not conceding but um i would say holding
the belief that the universe can exist
without a god-like being
right and that within itself will catch
a lot of people off guard so
like you said a lot of people think it's
common sense right because they are
brought up in this way
to them it's the only way um and it's
it's almost like a
superiority complex that they have that
um
if you don't and it's basically like
political correctness if you don't have
the stance this view
then you're wrong and it's i think it
goes back to the white man's burden
which is something that came up
during the uh the discussion the debate
but with these people a lot of time i
find that
they just have one underlying motivation
and they have this one drive which is i
want to
for this guy it just seems like he wants
to prove us them wrong for some reason i
think he even praised christianity um
and i saw a tweet about it that he was
praising christianity
um when you know them themselves in
their history have
very uh questionable things um and all
he does is attack this them so with
someone like that it's like
there isn't much for him to do except to
you know slip and slide and stutter just
trying to hit a very specific mark that
he
very clearly keeps on missing but um
looking back to that debate now
how do you look back on it how do you
view it well i think that
it was a good debate i did um
like he denies that it's a debate it was
a debate
but wait what did he think it was in the
beginning
i mean he claims now after you know
after the fact that it was just a
conversation
right it wasn't a conversation we should
have a real debate so basically he wants
a rematch
to save face he's like that was that
that didn't count you know that didn't
count so uh
that's that's what he says it was just
conversation but he was advertising it
as a debate like he put the thumbnail
in the youtube invitation or the um
like what's it called when you schedule
in advance the youtube live
there's a thumbnail that comes up and it
was daniel
versus apostate problems he put
as like verses so what does that mean
it's good and then
yeah he was like oh i didn't you know
think it was a debate otherwise i would
have prepared he's like he wants a
do-over basically
so i was like nah that's okay yeah five
hours of talking to you like if you had
anything of substance to say you could
have said within five hours
and it went so long because of him like
it wasn't supposed to be five hours or
four and a half hours wherever it was
it was supposed to be you know just like
a typical
length of a of a podcast but he just
kept extending it because he
wanted to like come out on top but he
just couldn't do it
so he just kept going on and on and on
but yeah
it was a complete embarrassment he like
uh unlisted the video
on his channel so you can't really see
me he was he was doing it live
on his channel i want to have my own
version on my channel
just in case he deletes it or tries to
like edit the video
so i i uh you know streamed it live on
my channel
and uh he just uh unlisted his so that
you can't in search for it
uh you can only find the version that is
on my channel
that's hilarious it's funny yeah that's
funny it shows how big his eagle
is so yeah he was considered the
like the intellectuals of the uh these
ex-muslims like he was like their main
guy
in terms of being so smart and having
all these great refutations against
islam
so it was kind of a blow to their morale
and their
sense of being so smart and intelligent
compared to muslims
i'm not saying that i'm so smart but
anyone who can string together a
coherent sentence
would have been better than him so
yeah yeah that's a lot but i mean at the
end of the day it's like
are you looking for the truth are you
looking for answers or are you just
trying to prove your point and if you
are just trying to prove your point then
that's like straight ego because at that
point like if you're proven wrong then
you can't step down
so you keep trying to bring something
else to the table so you can come out on
top like he was doing
yeah that's sad man yeah it's sad
like i've been in many situations
especially when i was younger like
in college and i thought i knew it all
and i would go into a conversation with
someone more knowledgeable and it would
become very clear
quickly that i just don't know enough so
i need to humble myself
and recognize someone who's is
smarter than me knows more than me so i
can benefit and learn
and improve myself like i'm the one who
loses
if i say oh i know better you don't know
what you're talking about
and just have this kind of ego defense
mechanism that's like a very arrogant
response and you're the main loser of
that
you have to you know and i experience
have experienced that many times in my
life
where okay clearly i am wrong about this
or i didn't
figure out this issue i need to go
research and i need to listen to those
who actually
know more so that i can improve and i
can get closer to the truth like because
that's ultimately what matters
what is the hop what is the truth and if
you don't have the hop
then you're going to be a loser so i
don't want that for myself
yeah that's facts man 100 and that
brings me to a very
uh interesting point that see we
initially planned that we're gonna you
know
talk about liberalism versus sharia law
we're 100 gonna go into that but
i want to know more now because you told
me that you had times in your life where
you had to step down
and kind of have that cognitive
dissonance when you had that paradigm
shift
so we want to know it all man tell us
about your upbringing i know your
parents are from
uh an iranian descent and you know you
are a revert yourself not really a
reaver but
you came to it on your own accord and i
want to know about that
kind of what brought you to islam school
the whole system
and just your old belief systems versus
now
yeah so i mean one example is that i was
raised as shia
like with a shia background i learned
how to pray and
practice islam as a shia and i believed
in like certain shia
points of belief like in terms of the uh
successor of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi sallam
being ali and it's
like those beliefs i had um and
then i came across sunni muslims
and talking to them i thought i was
right
and turns out i didn't like
understand a lot i didn't know a lot so
i did a lot of research
and you know long story short figured
out that
wow you know i can't continue to be shia
because
there's this problem there's this
problem there's this thing wrong and
when they were telling me
when others were telling me these
problems i said okay i need to go back
and i need to make sure i have the facts
and
that when i did that and read shia books
and did the research
in that tradition that i came to a to
the conclusion that i did
uh that's one example a lot of
uh liberal ideas i have myself
like if you're a muslim and you're
growing up in the west
and there hasn't been a real effort to
block or shield
these ideas then you just
absorb them like by osmosis like these
liberal ideas about like
you know there's really no difference
between men and women men and women are
exactly the same and you know the best
type of marriage is like an equality
marriage where it's a partnership
between man and wife
uh things about like violence
or war and all of these kinds of issues
or like governance like a secular
government a dem of course like
democracy where p
the masses just choose what they want of
course that's the best system
or that's the most just system of
government so these these kinds of ideas
uh i just assumed but
you know i was very quickly thanks to
good influence from
uh good brothers good friends good
teachers
alhamdulillah that allah put me in a
position to be influenced by
these people that i realized okay i'm
i'm
way off on a lot of my assumptions
and i'm just my entire world view
is based on very little like it's not
very solid at all
and it can be easily tipped over uh with
a slight push or with a slight breeze so
i better
you know get the facts educate myself
talk to people learn from them so that
was also a big
paradigm shift for me in my life and
this happened during college
so things like this also you know
there's so many examples
um like uh i'll give you one other
example
sorry to make it too long but the um
like intervention what's called
intervention in the middle east
like i was like okay yeah maybe saddam
hussein in iraq like maybe there's a
point
like if the u.s is trying to stop this
bad guy
right and you know going to war
i'm not a supporter or promoter of
saddam hussein obviously he
did a lot of terrible terrible things
but
i didn't have the same understanding at
that time i was in high school
in early college when the invasion
happened i didn't have the understanding
that
the u.s government can literally lie
lie and create evidence false evidence
to justify destroying a country
and killing millions of people i didn't
have that understanding
and if someone told would tell me that
at that time i might have a hard time
believing it
it was only later and this is when the
internet kind of
blew up in the early 2000s and
people now have other sources of
information you don't have to rely on
mainstream media news
that's just feeding you whatever lies
you know at the
time of the bush administration whatever
lies that they
are handing to these journalists and
these journalists are just like
dutifully recording it and passing it on
without any criticism without any
skepticism they just accept
oh yeah saddam has weapons of mass
destruction if we don't do something
he's going to nuke the entire world
he's the next hitler right no one is
questioning that
it's just like a question of okay should
we invade now
in the u.s should we invade now or
should we invade later or we should
should we just have sanctions
and starve them to death and deprive
them of like those are the two options
like should we just continue
starving them to death or should we
actually go and shock and
on war so like when i think about that
mentality
and you know i was young but still
that's not no excuse like you should
have known better should have had that
kind of information
and with the internet you can now go and
search and you can go and be
exposed to different ideas that will
shed light on the falsehood and the
fabrication
and that came to light later on as well
but that's another example of just a
paradigm shift you think that you can
trust
whatever comes from the mainstream the
experts the officials
government officials but they will
straight up lie they will straight up
lie
about so much and uh there was
one person was saying that he was
talking to his
chinese friend and his chinese friend
was saying that you know
i don't really follow chinese news
like i don't read the chinese newspaper
i don't watch chinese news channels
because that's propaganda and then that
the
the american guy was like oh well i
watch
all kinds of news and then the chinese
guy oh
you don't realize it's propaganda and
like american guys like i never even
thought
of that i like make the connection that
so all these news
in china and other countries we
recognize as americans oh that's just
state
propaganda state propaganda but if it's
american news no that's objective facts
being reported
and whenever you see like uh on facebook
and twitter like
uh from like russia today like that
particular
magazine that has a facebook uh
notification oh this is
russian state news or if it's al jazeera
this is qatari state news
whether it's new york times or
washington post there's no like
disclaimer
there listed with the article oh this is
just objective reporting
it's not american this is american state
propaganda they're not gonna
say that right so where's that's all you
need to know about the kind of bias that
is created
yeah matter of fact sometimes you even
see breaking or world news
that's about a lot this i think this is
obviously something that people need to
wake up to so inshallah this would be
the podcast that allows for that
um you know that amongst other things um
actually in
in the video that uh the the person you
you debated made
about a brother angel here one of the
first things he did
was laugh about um mass media
manipulation
and act like it's not a real thing
because one of the points angel made was
that you know he thought islam was this
really
you know terroristic religion and all
this weird stuff because that's what
you know mass media was was pushing and
the first thing that guy did was laugh
about it which i think is one of the
bigger blunders but
it's you know this is one one of the uh
the biggest issues we
you know we face as a society um we
always say the biggest problem you can
have is not knowing you have a problem
right
so not only are they being manipulated
but they're they're so lost they
they can't realize that they're being
manipulated right subhanallah
um so i i wanna i wanna talk a bit about
you know liberalism
the origin of it and and why it's so
destructive and
comparing it which was basically the
crux of that debate comparing it with
sharia
and everything why islamic law would
actually be
a lot better more beneficial for society
as a whole as opposed to something like
liberalism or another
secular mechanism
so yeah where would you say like as
heavy where would you say you know it
originated and why
did it originate liberalism
[Music]
yeah so liberalism came out of europe
uh france and britain and germany to a
certain extent
it started i'd say the origins are the
18th century
and it's a very basic idea that
look we don't trust the bible we don't
trust
the church to tell us what's right and
wrong
and the nature of the universe because
they're corrupt
and the bible actually there are so many
different interpretations this was
post-reformation so there was a conflict
and a lot of wars between catholics and
protestants
so that created a lot of doubt in the
bible so
we in this in 18th century
europe we don't really trust the bible
we don't trust the church we think it's
corrupt
we don't need them actually we can just
use our minds
and rationality to understand what's
right and wrong and how to live our
lives
and that's that's what liberalism is
this idea
we that can use our minds to determine
right and wrong
and the most important thing is
maximizing
a liberty maximizing people's ability to
choose whatever they want
and if people have the right to choose
whatever they want then they can make
the best choices for themselves
and uh we don't have the imposition
like the imposition of a church or the
imposition of a religion
or a king to control people and and
tell and make them do things that they
don't necessarily want to do
or things that are against their
interests so this is the basic
like motivating idea of liberalism and
when you just put it like that
seems like oh okay well that doesn't
sound too bad that
maybe i maybe that's what i think is
actually good maybe liberalism is on the
money actually
yeah it seems it's such like a
superficial way of looking at it right
like
that something because the first thing i
thought of when he described that is
that's so problematic
right maybe it's just the muslim in me
coming out but it's so problematic
because if everybody's doing what they
think is best for them
how would they know that's best for
society as a whole right and this is the
issue because if everyone is doing like
let's look at something like pornography
right a lot of people think this is
something that's good for them because
it makes them feel good
but how many you know people are
suffering with mental health issues
because of it how many marriages are
suffering
and consequentially how many homes are
being broken because of things like that
um but then again it's something that
people like to do therefore why it's
okay
so it just seems very problematic and
it's it's very superficial of people to
think that oh you know that
sounds like a good mechanism to me i
could do what i want to do um
but what do you know what if most people
are idiotic nowadays then you're just
gonna break society
um but how much of that do you think
influenced you know the islamic way of
thinking at that time because i was
learning in my in my class recently
that um this westernized ideology and
westernized philosophy
that came about after um you know like
kind of the secular secularism and and
these western ideologies
the muslim nations right the um at the
time they would look at the west and see
all the technological advancements they
had and the ways they were advancing
and they kind of tried to do this
deductive reasoning that oh
the only thing they left was their
religion
right therefore if we start leaving our
islamic ways of thinking maybe we will
advance in the way
they have so how impactful do you think
that way of thinking was on the islamic
way of thinking
well that's it wasn't really muslims
uh spontaneously coming to that
conclusion
uh because what happened was a colonial
program
and liberalism is really the religion
if you want to call it that of the
colonizer
and a lot of the finer points and
philosophy of liberalism
is a reaction to islam like they were
developing liberalism as an ideology
often in response to islam and wanting
to colonize muslims
so that's actually important to
recognize this kind of
intertwined history of colon colonialism
and liberalism but one of the things
that they
wanted to get muslims to do is to buy
european products especially european
technology
because if you can get a population uh
addicted to or reliant on
technology then you can lock them in a
position
of subsistence basically like they're
gonna be
less than you because your ship you're
taking their raw
resources for like pennies and then
you're selling them this technology
at high prices and basically entrapping
them
and locking them into this like low-tech
economy
right so this is a
economic subjugation of
you know the developing or the third
world or the
savage lands of the muslims like that's
that's a big
part of european colonialism but so they
they are telling so the way that they
sell the technology
is to say exactly this like look all of
the prosperity that we have
because of technology and what we did
was just change our
uh like we left our religion we
secularized
fine you don't wanna you muslims you
don't have to become atheists
no problem you can still be muslim but
just
you know drink some wine and
you know take off the hijab and shave
your beard
and don't dress like that just like us
you can still be muslim identify as
muslim
but you don't need all that but there
was a lot of resistance
from muslims uh and even jihad to the
against the colonizer
to avoid the technology technological
aspect too
and you know the biggest opponents of
some of these technologies
and it's because the scholars recognize
that these technologies
actually are going to destroy
muslim society and muslim culture and
enslave the muslim population
they recognize that but nowadays
unfortunately
people who are reading history and some
of these confused muslims who read
history were like oh look
see how backwards these scholars were
how anti-technology they were
and they like tried to belittle the
ulama because oh
muslims should have adopted this and
that technology
but they don't recognize the deeper
insight and wisdom that these
technologies will destroy
a way of life and we have you know we
have to recognize that about the nature
of technology
and our dependence on it is
not ideal right and this is not an ideal
like world that we're living in where
people are
controlled by technology i'll give you a
very specific example
like the printing press the printing
press seems like a great technology
because you can print all of these books
and that's spreading knowledge right
that's spreading all this information
but what happens like when you can print
a book
the way that knowledge was transferred
like religious knowledge
in the past amongst muslims is if you
want to learn
hadith for example or you wanted to
learn quran
you had to go to the scholar and travel
and sit with him and be with him for an
extended period of time
and actually hand write anything that
you wanted to record
and that created a relationship between
you and the scholar and the scholar can
make sure that you
understand and you kind of have to like
lower yourself
because you're traveling all the way
there and you need something from him
and so that's a very good relationship
because it is
analogous and parallel to the
relationship of the sahabah to the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
the sahabah were the students of the
prophet salallahu
and that's a very important type of
relationship for the transfer of
knowledge because knowledge is not just
facts on a page right knowledge is
behavior and
it's more spiritual than that so
the um printing press if you can just
print
books all of that goes away all of that
practice
all of that tradition is instantly uh
liquidated right because you don't need
if you want to learn that hadith
just go and buy the book from the
bookstore and now with the internet
just do a google search so it's no
surprise that even though
more like the actual texts
are more available than at any time in
history the amount of
actual knowledge and insight and wisdom
is at the lowest point of history
these things are related it's not a
coincidence and it's the technology that
has created this
this problem so of course the other male
were very cautious and
skeptical and i opposed these
technologies
and and one last point sorry i'm going
too long but if
leaving religion were really going to
bring this kind of utopia and success
there are so many places around the
world who
they have become completely secular and
they're still
third world developing right
uh so like look at different parts of
south america
africa the global south generally
eastern europe
greece like they've secularized
completely much more than muslims have
but where what technology has that gone
then it's
they've been diluted into you know this
kind of deal with the devil
and when you make a deal with the devil
you're going to lose yeah
man 100 uh yo before you go on i real
quick i wanted to say that
this when you were going on about
technology it reminded me that for the
first time i've seen in my 23 years of
life
that the amount of censorship during the
the election
now i'm not pro or against donald trump
and when we talk about on this podcast
conservative versus liberal we're not
talking about it in the political sense
we don't just because we don't agree
with liberal ideology and
politicism doesn't make us conservative
on the political spectrum by default
but when you saw what happened to donald
trump like he got i think removed from
facebook twitter
and he just it was crazy the president
of the nation
i've never seen something like that yeah
it's kind of like yeah it was shocking
it was really shocking and
i can't believe that there are countries
uh around the world that are not
regulating
facebook and youtube and all these
social media companies i think australia
tried to do something
but they folded right like they limited
or they put some
some penalties on facebook so facebook
ended up
shutting off all news in australia
through their platform
so that's that's nuts like that's too
much power
that they are using for their own
interests
so i don't know why any country in the
world would tolerate that
yeah subhanallah i i wanted to comment
on something you mentioned because uh
it sounds very similar to the hadith
apostle where he said that
um the ability to read and write will
increase right
but in in in certain things will
increase but knowledge will
decrease subhan allah and when i first
when i heard you say that
um that's so you know that's the first
thing i thought of subhanallah
and it's it's it's it's i feel like a
lot of people have a very shallow way of
thinking
even myself back in the day i heard a
certain scholar talk about
how you know the the scholars disagreed
with the printing press and me
young me hearing that was like what the
heck how backwards were these people
that
a printing press you have a problem with
that is this how strict they are in
their religion
right is how strict they are in their
views um and then
hearing quotes like um i believe it was
imam
allah saying something like if you're if
you study
and you're rigid in your views then you
don't know right if you're studying the
the you know
these rulings and you're really rigid in
these views of these rulings and you
don't even know them to begin with and
it's like
subhanallah the amount of of
superficial thinking that not only
people indulging
but people teach and preaches is really
insane i think this is the main problem
with you know
people having sahil bihari muslim all
these
hadith in the in and everything they'll
read one random passage
that'll strike the you know liberal side
of them and they'll be like wait what is
this
but they don't have the you know
contextual
analysis to it they don't understand in
you know the context
of which it was said what it means the
scholars what they what they say about
it
um and it's that superficial thinking
that i think is really
breaking us as a whole so
um let's let's if we take liberalism
right
what are some of the destructive
qualities of liberalism because you said
there you know
there are secularist countries that have
not gained anything from being you know
secularist countries or nations so if
you were to take secularism
secularism and liberalism um
deeply what would you say some of the
destructive traits of them are
well i mean for muslims so you can be
a muslim and be like liberal in this
idea of
freedom maximizing liberty
[Music]
maximizing democracy like democracy is
the best system
and separation of church and state is
the best system and
still call yourself a muslim but
it creates a cognitive dissonance for
you
because if you think about the
idea of secularism and separation of
church and state
and you feel like it's the best system
it's the most
just system then as a muslim you have to
ask yourself
why didn't the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
have a secular state and why isn't this
idea presented in the quran
the quran is coming from the creator of
the universe
who has created humanity and is sending
guidance
to all of humanity so why wouldn't the
most
just and the best system of life and of
governance
be included in that revelation
so this will create a theological doubt
this will cause like a cognitive
dissonance
and that is one of the biggest negative
impacts uh
for muslims and all other kinds of
issues like when it comes to equality in
marriage like okay the best
way to have a marriage is an equal
marriage where husband and wife are at
the same level
i know you guys have had many guests who
will talk about this concept
of how those kinds of marriages don't
work
like they just don't work and if you are
going to
abide by these liberal equality
standards
then your marriage is going to suffer
and you might find yourself divorced
like i was reading i mean there's so
many examples
and usually like reddit will have a lot
of these people posting
like she's a woman married for 18 years
to her husband they have these kids
like three kids and she just doesn't
respect her husband anymore because
he like got all these promotions and
he's like in the same job he was
five years ago and he like
stays at home and does chores and
she's just bored with him and doesn't
respect him and so she
wants to leave him after 18 years leave
the kids and go like find
an exciting guy and she doesn't know why
she has these feelings
right she doesn't understand why these
things are happening but it's because of
liberalism
it's because of this idea that you've
been fed that the best kind of marriage
to have
is one where men and women are at the
same level so i don't know if you want
to
operate i don't know how familiar your
guests are your audiences with
daniel man we gotta we gotta we gotta
send that husband you're talking about
the rational mailman so you can learn
about high programming
yeah but we'll we'll leave most of that
out
for our next recording because we we
want to go really deep into
feminism by programming all that
but yeah man there are some very good
points you brought up there i hear that
so much about women just
nagging and talking about you know and
frustrated about their their marital
life
i hear even more about women complaining
about their husband to other men
and those men then oh really he's like
that
don't worry i'm not like that
yeah it's like the um comments that you
see on youtube
where if it's like some feminist like
video
or like remember the gillette ads like
gillette
toxic masculinity and then the like the
top comments were oh my wife's boyfriend
really loves this video
my wife's things with the best kind of
shaving cream or whatever
it took me a minute but that's actually
kind of funny
but yeah there are people who someone
else a friend was telling me
i mean again maybe we should save it for
the next recording but
it was insane like someone else posting
online
about how he was fine with his wife
having a boyfriend you know he didn't
want to be a toxic male and try to
control his wife and prevent her from
experiencing her sexuality to its
fullest extent so he was okay like was
being uh cuckolded right that's like a
fetish
or a hot wifing or whatever they call it
and
um but then you know what happened
to his dismay is that that boyfriend
raped him the boyfriend
raped him say that one more time yeah
him the boyfriend
his wife's boyfriend ended up raping him
and so he's like trying to find some
online support like how should i feel
about this
like homophobic by not liking being
raped
oh my god oh my god
i don't know if that's real or not but
who knows like with this kind of
world that we live in things like this
might be happening yeah it's kind of
like oh i get a man
gone i was just gonna say like my
initial thought was a story like that
has to be fake but thinking about it
it's like
it could definitely happen in in you
know today oh age
1000 bro i always joke with my wife here
and there like
there's gonna be a day where we're
walking in public and it's gonna be a
crime to be heterosexual
like it sounds too like i'm capping or
it sounds way too out there
but the way society is propagating today
or should i say regressing
it's not too unfathomable especially you
know somewhere like the west where you
think oh
it's progressive and you know it's for
the people come on now
yeah subhanallah yeah
because they got raped by a guy nah
listen listen for us i get it bro it's
it's kind of hard to comprehend how
a man can have you in that position but
just think about it bro like if it is
true all right let's let's
let's put the skeptic skepticism aside
we got the muslim skeptic out here
putting his skepticism aside for a bit
so just think about it if it is true
just think about the state of that guy
his mental health there's so many guys
that i see articles about
i'm a modern man and i'm with a modern
woman so i allow her to go
do her thing become a woman you know
spread her wings and fly
during the day as long as she comes home
to me
at the end of the day so she's mine
i don't i don't get it i don't know
let's uh let's save the rest of this
discussion first yeah for sure bro
without diverging too too much um
but this is all this is all part of
liberalism though this is all part of
liberalism oh yeah
feminism includes it yeah liberalism
includes feminism too
i'm actually very excited for that
recording
so let's go back there there were some
things we were talking about that
other things that are damaging about
liberalism
yeah so unless unless you have more
points you want to make on liberalism
and how it could be damaging to society
as a whole
um if you want to talk about the concept
of an of the individual
during liberalism yeah absolutely like
uh because liberalism is
is constantly telling you that the
bottom line is
how you feel as an individual like what
makes you
happy you're number one right at the end
of the day
how you know your happiness your
ambitions
your goals that's that's all you need to
care about and
you'll have like some of these people
like um
life coaches or therapists or
psychologists will say that
look if anyone is getting in your way
in the way of your personal ambitions
just cut them out
cut them out of your life and
islamically like you can't
do that uh i mean there are cases where
you want to avoid being hurt
but you can't just cut your parents out
of your life just completely right where
you're not even
communicating with them uh and i'm not
trying to deny that some parents can be
abusive
but there's a right way and a wrong way
to go about it and
this individual mindset will lead you to
a lot of
unhappiness because when you put
personal ambition
you're missing a whole dimension of
human existence
where you want to care for people and
you want to sacrifice
for people your family especially right
so when you become a father and when you
become a mother
you have to sacrifice a lot for your
kids and you
you can't necessarily have all the fun
that you want you can't really
get to all those ambitions that you had
for yourself those dreams that you had
when you were younger so that's
sacrifice and sometimes you have to toil
and work really hard for your kids
right but that is will bring you another
kind of joy that will bring you another
kind of fulfillment and happiness
that is not like a physical pleasure
right so liberalism says no like
don't sacrifice for your kids and this
is why we see
marriage like the average age for
marriage is going up
up up and people just don't want to have
kids like why is that
why do people not want to have children
maybe it's because they're constantly
being told that kids are a burden
and you you shouldn't and it's true they
are a burden
but it's worth it it's something where
you put others above yourself as an
individual you are going to
be more fulfilled in your life and it
doesn't matter if you're muslim or
non-muslim this is a universal human
experience that comes from
human nature but liberalism is denying
human nature it's denying all of these
different aspects
of human nature like sacrificing for
your spouse or
sacrificing for your larger group right
as an ummah we're muslims you're part of
the ummah
right sometimes you gotta put your life
down on the line
for your brother right in
babel for example that's a sacrifice
that's
not putting your personal interests
above others
but you know jihad for civilians that's
one of the highest
forms of good deeds and acts you're
sacrificing for the sake of
allah you're sacrificing for the
interest of the ummah for the
for the larger muslim body this is
the most virtuous among the most
virtuous acts but liberalism
cuts that out and say no you're gonna
you know die or you're gonna get hurt
like you shouldn't do that like that's
contrary to your
liberty and your freedom so
you know think about number one always
think about number one
yeah uh you're right yeah it's almost
like it's like put your best interest
first
you know don't don't worry about kids
right now and they normalized it in
today's culture too that and you know in
18 years old you should be out of the
house man you should
cut off your parents it's normal that
you see in tv shows with
with this american you know you got the
son who's like oh did you are you in
touch with your dad
it's been you know nine eight ten years
since i since i spoke to him
i get it i was going to ask you a
question to anyone have you have you
read the way of men
the way of men no okay so basically
talks about
how back then you know our role as men
in societies and systems where we were
in tribes
and i know you know you know what i'm
talking about like you have to put the
good of the group first
oftentimes above your own personal
interests and
things that you want out to be right and
you look at the the sahaba and you look
at you know the companion of the
rasulullah and
that was the generation of men now
imagine these
men were kind of emotional and they were
like oh you know well i don't want to
have kids because it seems like a burden
and i don't think we wouldn't have islam
as we have it today yeah
absolutely absolutely
there's there's one point i wanted to uh
to mention back to the individual being
one
right the number one um to a certain
extent everyone has to wash your own
back right um
but you can only have one number one
right or like collectively society as a
whole can only have one number one so
there can't be a bunch of
individual number ones uh in all of
society
um because inevitably it's gonna crumble
if everybody
only cares about themselves right when
there should be a greater goal a greater
purpose
and um it's amazing that you know islam
because without islam we wouldn't really
have this this proper
you know understanding of it of you know
sacrifice and everything
uh especially like the sacrifice you
know of a mother and how she has three
times over the father and
and all the stuff and all the marital
communion
and and family matters and all that
subhanallah
and it it's it's funny because if
everybody you know has their own best
interest
what if they don't really know what
their best interest is because a lot of
the people think this short term
gratification is their best interest
all right and what that does is feed
long-term depression which i feel
is the reason why so many people suffer
from it today because they've
essentially
neglected themselves inevitably being
told that
these are your desires and since you're
free you should go after your desires
not knowing that they've now become a
slave to
their desires that this mechanism of
liberalism
is actually making them a slave to
something that's going to ruin them
whereas in islam you know if you're a
slave to allah
that's the only way to truly be free as
an individual and maximize
on you know your fit yourself as a human
and not experience this in saying
cognitive dissonance depression anxiety
and all the stuff that
we're experiencing nowadays as an ummah
so with that being said for us nowadays
you know we're struggling may allah make
it easy for us what would you say
the the solution is for us
well there's not gonna be an easy
solution because this is like a global
system and it's being
implemented by force so
it's going to be very hard to resist it
there are certain measures that you can
take to reduce the influence of this
global system i think one of the
most effective ways is to disconnect
yourself from
mainstream media disconnect yourself
like
stop allowing that poison to affect the
way that you view the world
and that will have a big positive effect
instead
plug yourself into good sources of
information
about the world it doesn't have to be
like
a religion or religious sources
it's obviously good if you learn your
deen and study islam
but just in general in terms of being
informed about what's happening
find alternatives like alt
kind of media alt alternative and
as of now it's available online like
they haven't shut everything
down yet that might change uh god knows
allah knows
but for now uh you have the option to
unplug from mainstream that's number one
number two
uh really try to learn more about
liberalism and the way that it operates
i offer courses uh through my institute
at leicester institute and they go into
depth also
my youtube channel and website go into
depth on liberalism so you can always
use those resources and then third i
would say
try to focus on family and try to focus
on getting married to someone who's good
who
is on the same page as you and you know
gets it
uh try to get married try to have a
strong
family and raise your kids well and
raise your kids
uh so that they're not liberals and they
don't have these liberal biases that we
grew up with
or at least i grew up with um
and it's important why is family
important because
people around you and the way that you
live life has a psychological effect
right um just reading something
in a book or on a website is not
necessarily going to change your way of
thinking
but being around different people and
living in a different way of life
will or has a much more much more
impactful way
of thinking in your psychology so alter
your psychology
by building a family like a strong
family
and connect with other families or your
own extended family try to move closer
to them
these are all practical things that you
can do that are very important if we
live individualistic lives then we're
going to think in individualistic ways
our psychologies are going to be primed
in a way that makes liberalism more
appealing
and you can't necessarily consciously
know about that
impact on your mind but it's there it
happens
sucks before we take forward i just
wanted to ask angel do you have any like
thought or two that you want to get out
there
because you've been quiet unless you're
just you know taking in i don't know i'm
just i'm taking it in but i'm
real tired so forgive me if i'm
extra but i quiet say
like what you're saying right now uh
would did you say something before i
said
oh i was wondering why you're tired oh
man
i just i'm shifting my sleep schedule
i'm waking up but like anywhere from
like four to five a.m
getting in all the prayers uh
but on top of that man i did a workout
like my neck i trained my necks on my
necks like giving out right now
uh but what you were saying about this
whole liberalism liberalism thing
um i i think that i experienced this
firsthand because um i i
had family but like since my mom and my
dad got divorced when i was young
and my mom and me and my sister moved
over here
i was like four years old we
you know we kind of spent some time with
family but like it wasn't really like
that big of a
deal they're like big family
get-togethers like
it was very rare and i remember when i
was in my ex
uh her family was like really tight so
like for me to see
the difference of like having a family
who's like really tight where it's like
they have like 8 10 15 people staying in
like one house
all like they have holidays or they
treat almost every weekend as a holiday
well they're all getting together and
they have like 50 80
100 people and like it gets here i'm
like jeez like so this is
it like this is what it means to like
actually have a family and
i mean it's just it it links together
that's
that's what liberalism does it like
separates you
yeah bro i just wanted to kind of
polish your point right there with some
points that you are 100 right and
there's ways it's manifesting in society
for one you're saying that you need a
strong family right to like
proliferate the ummah keep everyone in
their role keep everyone in their frame
but
how are you gonna do that when people
are confused about their gender identity
and all that because that directly
prevents you from you know reproducing
because today you have
you have people that you got two women
that are like oh i could be happy with
you know each other and we can
adopt uh you know a kid or we can get a
dog and
that's like that's our life like i don't
i don't get it man it's it's so
normalized today that
people are not even put off by the
thought of living life and not having
kids
yeah i mean it's not having family what
yeah my bad um i was there bro
like i i used to think to myself like i
don't want kids
i don't care about having a family like
i'm fine if i
if i'm like 40 50 years old i'm not
married and i don't have kids but then
by now that i think about i'm like
[Music]
that would be pretty lonely
do you want any kids no romney has kids
okay mommy you can say man you could say
it bro it's okay
yeah i have four quadruplets
you have four quadruplets so you have 16
kids 16.
[Music]
with one more series you have you have
quadruplets no no no no i don't have
i'm 20. that means romney's the youngest
of all of us uh
yeah okay don't bro don't say you're 20
like it means that's such a liberal
statement bro back at the time of the
sahaba bro
you could be 20 with 20 kids that's fair
that's first
the thing that you don't really realize
until you have kids like there are
certain
emotions that you have yet to experience
as a man and you are not going to
experience them
until you have kids so like
people are interested in experiences
right that's like the kind of
youth culture or western culture like oh
i want to have more experiences like go
to cancun or go travel the world to have
these experiences right
but there is no experience that you can
have that's
like having a child and feeling certain
emotions
and that's an uh dimension of human
existence
that you can't really enjoy uh
until you have uh until you have
children so
i definitely recommend you know brother
and
for guys it's easier
for guys it's easier because you guys
don't have a we don't have a fertility
window right you could be 80 and still
have kids
yeah uh but um yeah highly recommended
but
unfortunately a lot of like how do you
get the mindset
how are people being brainwashed into
thinking that yeah
kids aren't something that i really need
or want
right my grandfather had 20 kids
20 kids yeah that's a battle
he did not waste time yeah he was
sufficient
he got the three wise to listen this is
what we're gonna do
we got eight months here eight months
over there eight months over here
cycling through it ladies cycling
[Laughter]
through
yeah so because uh he would he would
travel for work
and like between two cities and the
cities weren't like that far apart
like maybe like a 45 minute drive or
less
but he had like one wife in each city in
those two cities
his first wife passed away uh he only
had like
two wives at the same time but uh
they were just in two different cities
and so he would be
like few days in one city he'd have a
wife there a few days in another city if
wife there so that's that's how he set
it up actually
his uh one of his wife's his second wife
was like look you're spending all this
time in this other city
and i'm not there to take care of you so
you need to get a second wife or you
know other than me
it would be his third wife but just have
another one in that city
and so she can take care of you
that's for real man i really
listen um what we talked about so far is
good and
you know i want to talk about a little
bit about pelogeny as well on our next
episode
but to continue this this point that we
were on the momentum about uh
liberalism today we we live in a
unprecedented level of
seclusion right and division so
muslims now that are watching this
they're like okay liberalism
is cancer like we can't we can't be
you know when it's time to vote who do
we vote then do we vote conservative or
do we
do we vote liberal like i hear the joke
all the time it's like
like liberal governments they're okay
with the mosques
but it's like you need to put this lgbtq
propaganda in the mosque
and then with conservatives it's like no
no mosque you know so
they don't they don't know what to do
and even in the umma
right it might not be too relevant but
we can even get into that
um because i feel this calling that even
in the ummah there's so much division
right yes there's you know we have
different sects within islam
we can talk about you know sunnisha and
all that but
this this whole division is is a way to
just destroy people and it starts at the
individual level with dividing the
family
but why don't you give us a little bit
about what muslims can do today
when they're pulled apart by you know
society trying to pull them towards the
left or the right
and even within the ummah because we
have people commenting that hey i'm
shi'a
and i feel like i want to you know leave
and come into sunni
were people saying oh why is sunni islam
the one
right so
your question is like how to be unified
unified within one society politically
and two within them
within society muslim and non-muslim
like in western society
yes yes that when you got a vote
things like that well you know i've been
living in the west
my whole life i'm not sure if i'm going
to be living in the west
for the rest of my life but
you know i've had no trouble as a muslim
um in the sense of like
feeling like i'm separate from others
like i don't feel isolated
um you do have to isolate yourself in
some
circumstances right and by isolate i
mean
just being around muslims
as a social alternative so when i'm in
college
and there are these different activities
you have all kinds of choices
uh you can go to hang out with this
group or that group
i'm just going to be more comfortable
around muslims i have to pray for
example
i'm gonna pray with them in the masjid
in the word
i'm go i wanna go eat so i'm gonna go
eat
go hang out after exams or whatever
it's gonna be with muslims because
they're the ones who care about halal
so you're just going to be gravitating
towards muslims
and there's room for that like why
wouldn't you
like you want to be around people who
are in the same
mindset as you and everyone accepts that
so i don't know if that answers your
question
about society okay
and then yeah i mean i think that
some muslims do feel isolated if they
don't have
family number one around them and then
number two if they don't have muslims
around them or muslims that they're on
the same wavelength with
you know because i've also lived in
places where
there was the masjid and but it was like
mostly people were much older than me
and didn't speak english
for the most part so i was isolated at
that time of my life
because there wasn't like people my age
or my with my
interests muslims in that message so i
felt isolated but
you know you get through it there are
different stages in life and you work to
find good people you surround yourself
with good believers so that they have a
positive impact on you
and when you don't do that and you
resort to people who have a completely
different
understanding of the way to live life
that can be dangerous for you
and i've seen many examples of muslims
who felt isolated
and for whatever reason sometimes it was
not their fault
like they were just in a bad
circumstance and
they went and hung out with a lot of
non-muslim friends
and then when you and this is the hadith
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
sallam that a person is on the religion
of his friends his close friends
so if you bring those kinds of people
into your
life who will drink they will
you know commit zina they don't care
about allah they like
they can go for days without god
coming onto their tongues then
i mean i have i have many neighbors in
the in the past when i was in the
corporate world
uh co-workers employers who were
non-muslim and
no problem getting along with them but
would i consider them to be like a
khalil
which is the word in the hadith that the
prophet saw allah uses which means close
friend
no they weren't they weren't like my
best friends
i wasn't spending so much time with them
because
that can threaten and endanger like your
heart
your heart is affected by your
environment so
never sacrifice your heart and the state
of your eman
just for socializing uh it might be hard
if you're
in a certain part of your life but don't
try to like if you know that what that's
what you need don't compromise on your
iman
and endanger your email instead try to
go to
somewhere else where you'll be
influenced positively and there are many
examples
from hadith about this and then the
other
thing that you said about the umma as a
whole
to stick together by the rope of allah
come together
and unite and do not differ and
what's important about this verse of the
quran is
the rope of allah is sent by allah it's
something that
is coming down to us it's revelation so
we as a
ummah have to always be united on the
truth
and it's very clear those who are
concerned about the truth and want to
stick to the truth
and those who just want to be in in
their different
fit up in their different uh sect
and they want to just differentiate you
know us versus them
and that's what they're constantly
concerned with as opposed to the truth
the haqq
and sticking to the quran and sunnah
because everyone agrees there's the
quran
and the sunnah right and if
you are sincere and wanting to follow
that then it's very clear who
is sincere in that and who is just
wanting to
divide off and be like no this is us and
that's you
yeah so um and that's why i became sunni
like
i'm concerned i am concerned about quran
and sunnah
and shia are supposed to be concerned
also about quran and sunnah well if
you're concerned about the foreign then
read it and it's saying xyz
right so then are you going to accept
that are you going to just stay
according to what you your group is and
what your
family is i didn't want to do that
exactly uh we're going to come back to
this after the quick point that i had
on your previous um you know the the
line you were dropping about
uh you know you become the people you
surround yourself with
right if you hang out with people that
are drinking you're gonna do that
eventually
now dr zakir naik made a video i was
watching one day where
he made a point about um you know a
woman asked him is it okay to have
non-muslim friends
and he said yeah you know at least his
opinion on it was
yeah it's okay to have non-muslim
friends we live in a society but
provided that you
are influencing them or you're a role
model for them
more than they are for you because if
they are influencing you
more than you're influencing them it's
it only leads one way
and you know we don't need to say it but
it only leads that way it might not be
there tomorrow it might not be there by
the end of the day but
it only leads there in totality so
that was his point and i agree but we
get a lot of people that are in our
requests in our in our inbox that are
saying stuff like i'm not a muslim
but within my jahilia days i was you
know hanging out with people that were
drinking
or i myself i used to smoke and you know
these are the only people i have
now they're not bad people per se but
they partake in a life
in activities you know in just a
lifestyle that is not aligned and
congruent with
my you know belief system now with islam
what do i do do i cut these people off
do i
limit my association with them do i
associate with them but not partake in
the activities they're doing
while they are partaking in those
activities and still put myself in that
situation
or do i just you know just play by ear
so what do you say to people like that
it's hard to give a general rule um
i think you know it really depends on
your definition of friend
who what does it mean to be a friend um
and like i said like i have to this day
like people who maybe they would
consider
in their definition that i'm their
friend like non-muslims
um because i'm just friendly i
you know will talk to them ask them how
they're doing i'll be concerned like oh
you're sick can i do anything to help
you
uh i'll be their friend like that but do
am i spending like quality time with
them am i like really
am i like going to tell them my most
vulnerable
things like i would with a close friend
like my bff
uh no like the thing is that you
like the people who are really
influencing you are your best friends
your closest
inner circle and you want to make sure
that that close
inner circle is good people because
those are the people that you could end
up
being resurrected with like in
yomokiyama when allah is going to raise
you
it's going to raise you with the people
that you love
right the people that you are so close
to
that you love them and you don't want to
be raised if someone is bad
right and you know that they're doing
the wrong thing they believe the wrong
thing
like they're worshiping you know a
man or they're worshiping other gods you
don't want your
afterlife to be tied to that so you have
to be
very practical this is not a joke like
we only get one chance at life
and you don't know if how long you're
gonna live tomorrow
you know i might be gone in the next ten
minutes you know i might end this call
with this uh with you guys and that's it
so i want to make sure that
i'm not taking any chances with my and
your close friends
and the people that you love in that way
that is a big factor
that is a huge huge factor so don't
gamble with that
and again i have plenty of good
relations with people non-muslims
and not so pious muslims like my
in my own family my extended family not
everyone is a muslim in my extended
family
and not everyone is a good muslim in my
extended family obviously
but i still have a connection with them
and i'm still nice and friendly i help
them
and it's my duty to do that um so
don't get me wrong here but you just
have to be
cautious it's not like don't think about
it in terms of
what do i stand to gain think about what
do i stand to lose
by uh my associations because um
it's very critical yeah subhanallah
bro we got man that's gonna stay with me
for
for a couple hours after this call it's
not about what you can gain from them
but
it's potentially where you can lose
subhan allah
um when i when i first you know really
came to islam when i first really came
back to islam
when i was like 16 17.
majority of my close friends people who
i'd hang out with and talk to
were non-muslim i went to a catholic
school by the way right
so there's catholicism like all around
me um and most of my friends were either
non-muslim
or muslim by name like i was uh and
indulging some very you know
haram things and what i did when i first
came to islam is
naturally i kind of internalized the
hadith of the process
where he said that loneliness is better
than bad company
but good company is better than
loneliness and naturally i just kind of
ended up isolating myself from them and
i didn't for a while i didn't really
have anyone i didn't have a problem with
that but for a while i didn't really
have anybody
and i kind of made you know youtube
lectures and and islamic videos like
my companion my friend and uh i would i
would literally
listen to them constantly i would watch
debates i was i would listen to like
uh speaker corner videos and even some
of your videos actually
love back in the day may love blessing
reward you so that's something that i
found myself doing naturally when i
didn't really
have anyone and i think it's really
crucial because i feel like if i had
stayed close with them
um i may have even lost my islam so
alhamdulillah i'm glad that you know i
was alone for all those years
and i don't think being alone is
necessarily a bad thing i think
not being able to be alone is a lot
worse a lot of people feel like they're
they're not able
to be by themselves nowadays subhanallah
yeah for sure i think a lot of people
also are losing the ability to
find friends i know i have a big
issue with finding friends i don't know
like i'm
considered to like my personality type
is more introverted anyway
but like i have a hard time
after college especially in college it
seems to be very natural like you just
go
and it's easy to find muslims especially
because i was living in boston so there
are a lot of colleges like
it's like a college town so there's a
lot of people that you can go
hang out with and same age same kind of
interests
but uh then after college it was more
difficult
for me to like find people i got married
pretty early so that kind of
you know my my friend is just gonna be
my wife we'll just hang out and
socialize
but if you don't have that then it can
be very isolating and
and lonely but that's a very good point
like sometimes you just have to
it's like a test this is this is a kind
of test are you going to
bear the discomfort of being lonely uh
or you go and like preserve yourself or
are you gonna sacrifice
dean and kind of put yourself in a
precarious situation with people who
might lead you down the wrong path and
then if you make that sacrifice then
allah will give you
the best friends that you never knew
that you could have
and the people who will really inspire
you
and uh inshaallah lead you to jannah
but i mean i'll give you a personal
example
story from my family in my life so
you know alhamdulillah i was very
blessed by allah
to be able to find good muslim brothers
in high school and that's pretty much
how i came to practice
islam in high school and eventually
became sunni from shia
it was because of coming across the msa
muslim student association
in my high school and um
it was just by you know by chance quote
unquote like from my perspective
i overheard some muslims just talking
about this msa that they wanted to form
and i thought msa
what what what's that like i was just
overhearing their conversation
and they blew my mind wow muslims
actually do stuff like they get together
and pray this these were foreign
concepts to me like i knew how to pray
and i knew basics about islam but i
hadn't
maybe gone to masjid my parents hadn't
taken me to a masjid or introduced me to
that
growing up maybe i had only been once or
twice so then because of that
overhearing that i was interested so i
ended up going to their first meeting
like the msa meeting that they just
formed
and that was the beginning of like my
friendships with these good muslims
so alhamdulillah that influenced me in a
very good way in my life
but uh i had another family member
uh actually it's my sister and my
younger sister she's two years younger
she
unfortunately fell into a very bad crowd
and she had the same exact background as
me
uh she is smarter than me she had like a
higher sat score
and mashallah but she just fell into a
wrong crowd and these were kids that
were smoking a lot and they were
uh you know doing all kinds of wrong
things uh in high school
and some of them i think were even in
trouble with the law like they might
have been in
juvie like juvenile hall but that those
became her friends
and she felt comfortable around them she
became acclimated to them
and so she started changing and
unfortunately this led her to starting
to to do
to drink for example and smoke and those
kinds of things
so you know and that sent her to a
completely
different path and i'm sharing this
because i think it's
very important to get across the danger
of having
the right friends and she went missing
basically because she went to a party
and this was in 2007
so she actually she was
20 years old i believe and at that time
and she went missing and has been
missing like no one knows where she is
and police like did searches like people
suspects were identified and questioned
one guy went to jail being involved with
her
going missing so that's you know
something that's affected
my life but it always makes me remember
like the
the importance of having the right
people around you like
yeah like you're asking is definitely on
the line your dunya is also on the line
like the rest of your life is online
depending on who you
uh spend your time with
i think that's the one that's one thing
a lot of people end up missing out on um
they think islam is all about you know
the afterlife but they they
they neglect the fact that living a life
of islam
right living on the deen of islam is the
best way to live this life and it's
going to bring about the most benefit in
this life and the next
so it's either you win win or the other
end if you neglect
islam you're losing it's lose lose for
you um
and uh i actually i wrote a poem on on
this concept that you know
uh if you know a lot of the time people
think like i i wish i just knew what was
gonna happen right
i wish i just knew you know when i'm
gonna find love when i'm gonna find
these friends when i'm gonna
get this job so on and so forth and it's
like if i knew these things and i'd feel
a lot more comfortable so i
basically wrote about you know if you
knew your you know
like the love of your life because this
is back before you know we had these
discussions uh the love of your life if
you knew they were coming you know
um you would have this like mysterious
devotion to them before even knowing
them you wouldn't have
stress fear anxiety and i end off by
saying but
imagine how how strong we would be if we
believed in these things
even when we didn't know for a fact
right and that's essentially you know
having trust in allah and in god
consciousness knowing that
um if you give something out for the
sake of allah he will replace it with
something better you know
i uh very naturally when i said you know
i left my friends
little did i know i was gonna run into
fire at the gym asking him how to do
tricep extensions you know to fix my
form
and you know subhanallah all this time
later now we have a podcast
subhanallah so it's it's really complex
how how
life works and you know but one of the
names of allah is is the subtle right
and he he really he works in very
beautiful and subtle ways sometimes and
i feel like if people can internalize
that and know that it's a small changes
in life that have bigger greater
outcomes kind of like the butterfly
effect
then um there would be a lot more
content with even their the low
lows in life subhanallah
yeah that's that's profound
man all this time that uh brother danny
was talking about you know the role of
the family
it just got me thinking man how how many
times we're just ungrateful for our
parents
now it might be you know going off on a
slight tangent but
i i watched a video about daniel talking
about how
you know when anything happens you know
the way society conditions
us today this is just abort our
appearance and to just leave be like
okay
you guys did this cool call us peace you
know because that's that's essentially
what we see on the media
but it's like putting together the
pieces now everything's connected
growing up like for example my parents
they were working right they
obviously like the way society is
structured you know it's unless you have
you know super high earning you know
passive income from home
parents got to be out there in the
workforce right but my parents
whenever there were things like work
parties or like events or like
conferences or something that's not
mandatory
i can't think of one time where they
went they would always stay you know
with me
making sure we're straight making sure
you know we have family time even if
it's once a week even if it's twice a
week
that we have that consistent scheduled
routine time
where we do things or we go on trips we
go on vacations
so i just want to give a quick shout out
to my parents and any other muslim
parent right now
that always put the family first because
when the family crumbles beyond nothing
may allah have mercy on our parents and
bless them immensely
may allah you know allow us to be good
children because um
said that there will come a time when
you know a slave gives birth to a slave
owner
right imagine living in that state you
know treating
your mother like a slave when janna is
under her feet
and you should you know not that
children should be slaves to their
parents but if there's
going to be a slave to someone you're
definitely going to have to be a slave
to your mother not the other way around
subhanallah
if you want to achieve jannah imagine
the state of ingratitude you would have
to to be in you know for allah for your
parents for your life
and that's something we fall into
subhanallah
protect us from that man
i think we're we're 30 minutes um out of
schedule i think we
were good to wrap it up i don't know i
don't know you got anything else to say
or you you he's gonna have a lot to say
on thursday
you know i'm interested in that but i
was interested in this too i'm just
really tired y'all
it was good though that was good your
presence is held on matters
so you guys do a lot uh you lift a lot
of weights
oh does romney's starting to
i just i do it for like strength and
conditioning for martial arts
oh nice yeah that's
yeah i used to before i got busy with
family i
used to hit the gym too and i played
that i used to play a lot of basketball
but
i oh we got another hooper yeah
i would i would do uh weightlifting just
to get my vertical up
so i like to what was your vertical at i
didn't measure it at the peak but i
could dunk in high school so
one hand and i need a running start
how tall are you uh six
two almost with shoes okay so you about
about the same size as uh
sarami over here yeah about about an
inch taller
masha allah masha'allah we should all
get together inshallah one day and have
a game
um we can get ibn mura and and all the
other hoopers on here
[Music]
yo the day we the day we chop it up with
muhammad hijab or we'll ask him to come
to how tall is he
what this dude is like seven feet tall
bro
[Music]
yeah but very quick before i forget it
top of my mind um
daniel if people want to find you they
like what you're talking about
they want to support the movement they
like your ideology where can they find
you
uh they can just go to muslimskeptic.com
that's where i have a lot of material
it's not just me it's a lot of other
muslims who are writing that's my
website
and then there's also um facebook
twitter uh telegram now telegram is
pretty cool
i have my own channel there and youtube
it's muslim skeptic
if you just search it search my name
you'll get the channel and the institute
is atlesna.org
um and i have classes on their courses
pre-recorded that people can sign up if
they want to
get through like it's not i wouldn't say
it's like college courses
because it's more convenient it's like
pre-recorded so you can follow on your
own schedule
but it's like academic material and
people who want
like a more in-depth understanding of
modernism feminism
um liberalism we actually have a
marriage course too it's more practical
like
how to practically get married as a
muslim that's
um it's like a 20-hour course that
people are taking and i
co-teach it with my wife whom caught it
so yeah you can follow me on those on
those sources inshallah
inshallah i'm gonna link everything in
the description but real quick
you said telegram is you could have
channels in the post up there
yeah no way i thought it was just a
message you got
no no it's much better than other apps
messaging apps it has that function but
you can create
what they call a channel and people can
just
join it um and yeah you just
post whatever you want and it's good
if you don't want anyone to comment like
you just want to post
material so i use it to share memes i
use it to share articles
uh random thoughts and that's good i
like it a lot
[Music]
may allah make um you know all these
mean sources of good
uh for the people and foreign
[Music]
do you guys have anything to say i don't
i was gonna ask one question would you
say you uh like there's any specific
field
um that you're studying in islam like or
like
what i'm studying yeah uh yeah so right
now i'm going through a curriculum
and i'm studying i'm studying
i'm studying um like the philip
of ibadat and also mohammed
so right now i'm on kitab and nikah
and i just had my exam on
one of these texts actually four
different exams on four different texts
one was in usual hadith and i think i
did okay
i don't think i failed out but yeah
i'm in the middle of that stuff right
now alhamdulillah
all right guys if you made it this far
we're about an hour and a half just over
that in
comment down hashtag muslim skeptic
stay tuned for our next episode where we
will talk about
feminism and the effect it has not only
on women but on men
looking forward to it
we uh we appreciate you having on
masha'allah it's a pleasure for us
definitely may allah reward you
immensely and make this a source of good
for the people
thank you all for watching may bless you
all we'll see you on the next one
insha'allah
do this and like your foreplay could
literally consist of nothing but that
y'all could not even have sex and she
would literally
submit to you in every single way even
after the fact
and i i speak that from experience but
um
for a lot of purposes if you do that
with your wife
you will see crazy things and if you're
a woman watching this
throw this over to your husband so he
can learn
the game if you're doing it properly and
stuff where she
climaxes even if it's just minor ones
multiple times before you even actually
start
you know having the real intercourse and
when you get to that point you know
you're doing it right
what i wanted to add about this whole
foreplay thing
is that a woman has
three stages of orgasm
have an orgasm stage one
all right stage two is orgasm from
penetration or orgasm from your finger
penetrating and hitting the g-spot
that's
like three four or five times before
penetrating like you really don't have
to go fast at all
you could keep it super slow and just do
exactly what fire was uh
showing there and like you'll probably
have a bus another few times before it's
your time
yeah if if your akita your beliefs and
your sex life are both in line and
they're both good
you're gonna be fine and that's the kind
of the fundamental the the basis of it
right in that connection
you have the actual you know emotional
connection with your beliefs and
everything being aligned
you have the sexual connection with you
which is the intimacy being in line both
are necessary you need them
um so focus on that and just think about
how many things you didn't know
that we just talked about now right and
i'll think about how much
more there is that you probably don't
know because you grew up in a society
where they don't talk about these things
and they're shunned
they shouldn't be shunned because if
they're shuns then you won't have good
intimacy then your marriage breaks apart
then your family breaks it's not enough
all the time
you need to break a part of that being
said may i bless you all and grant us
good spouses and children who will be
the coolness of our eyes and allow us to
be leaders for the righteous people
[Music]
i feel emotional right now man
i feel emotional my eyes tearing up bro
man it's just bro it's
it's real man because
yes bro you go through these things and
you're right bro it's like these things
happen
and and um you know that you
you're not giving more than you can but
dude like
i look back and i'm just like damn bro
that [ __ ] was tough bro that [ __ ] was
tough y'all can bleep that out man
well that was tough bro and
it does bro it does make you into who
you are so like people who are going
through something
you know mentally mentally you will
put yourself down after the abuse ends
but like that doesn't that doesn't mean
that you have to
that doesn't mean that you have to and
it's like mentally you think you're
nothing that you're not worthy of
anything that you
are the same thing that this other
person was putting you down to be
but it's like i had to go through all
these things and like for myself i
realized like
dude i'm so much more i'm so much more
than
what this person was making me out to be
and whoever is going through something
like you as well
so much more
[Music]
[Music]
um